und das ist der nordrhein-westfälische
ministerpräsident hendrik wüst bei uns
bei bild live gleichzeitig der chef der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz herzlich
willkommen hier die zahlen jetzt gerade
gehört von patricia es gab aber richtig
probleme heute bei den zahlen beim
robert-koch-institut haben ja die server
heute herum gesponnen haben sie
vertrauen jetzt in die aktuellen zahlen
dass die sind ja nicht ganz unerheblich
das sind die zahlen die heute auf den
tisch kommen beim corona gipfel ja wir
kommen heute mittag zusammen ich denke
da werden wir schon überarbeitete zahlen
abend aber unabhängig von der frage wie
sich jetzt heute die zahlen entwickeln
sehen wir ja die infektionszahlen sind
zu hoch wir sind am anschlag was die
krankenhäuser angeht wir müssen
unglaublich vorsichtig sein aber wie
kann das sein dass immer wieder die
zahlen nicht aufschlussreich sind also
wir haben uns jetzt zusammen gesucht was
wir tatsächlich für aufschlussreich
halten aber beim robert koch institut
nach so langer zeit corona krise gibt es
immer wieder fehler immer wieder guckt
man morgen ist drauf immer wieder kommt
der hinweis nach dass bundesland oder
der landkreis hat heute aber nicht
gemeldet dass doch total unbefriedigend
ja ist es teile ich auch dass am
wochenende teilweise nicht gemeldet wird
deswegen ist die sieben tages inzidenz
glaube ich ein guter wert wenn er das
alles raus mittel und das ist ja nach
wie vor auch einer der zentralen
steuerungs werte für die politik jetzt
muss heute ja über einiges geredet
werden und eigentlich sind wir alle
schon in weihnachtsstimmung also jetzt
noch meine mpk de klar dass wurde
beschlossen bei der letzten mpk danach
fragt man sich dann jetzt passiert doch
nicht noch irgendwas jetzt wird doch
nicht noch irgendwas beschlossen dass
uns das weihnachtsfest vermiesen könnte
oder doch diese
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz ist keine
sondersitzung zu corona also keine
alarmstimmung sondern es ist eine der
zwei regelmäßig stattfindenden mit der
bundesregierung insofern war auch ein
paar andere themen belarus europa solche
dinge aber natürlich wird corona auch
wie eine rolle spielen vorher ist es
immer wir müssen endlich deutschland für
den corona winter winterfest machen das
war das wort vom jetzigen kanzler olaf
scholz aber ich habe mir gehört jetzt
sind wir soweit jetzt sind winterfest
würden sie sagen wir sind corona
winterfest na da wäre ich sehr
zurückhaltend omikron ist noch viel zu
wenig erforscht
wir haben inzwischen ein verfestigt
eindruck so will ich mal sagen dass die
infektiosität deutlich höher ist also
einen punkt wo man sagt jetzt ist
erstmal gut das halte ich für riskant
deswegen müssen wir weiterhin er sei
jetzt hier sie haben uns ja gesagt uns
deutschen wir machen das jetzt wir
regeln das jetzt wir machen deutschland
winterfest oder aussage von olaf scholz
ja es war das ziel von olaf scholz bevor
als omikron gab dafür muss man jetzt
auch wohl wir anderen parteien angehören
fair mit ihm umgehen wir müssen
vorsichtig sein mindestens omikron band
uns dazu aber schon auch die
infektionszahlen der letzten woche die
werden wir ja alle in einer bestimmten
entsprechung 0,7 prozent ist die alte
erkenntnis ich hoffe wir müssen keine
neue lernen bei omikron 0,7 prozent der
menschen die in den letzten tagen
infiziert worden sind werden auf der
intensivstation landen omikron hin
omikron her das kann es noch viel
schwieriger machen deswegen absolute
vorsicht und konzentration nach wie vor
ich weiß man kann ich in die glaskugel
blicken dennoch fragen wir uns natürlich
alle wie soll das ganze weiter gehen
wird es immer weiter eine mpk geben dann
wieder weitere beschlüsse wird es immer
wieder eine neue variante da sind alle
keine virologen und dennoch hat man ja
seine persönliche einschätzung dafür wie
lange begleitet uns dieses ganze thema
dennoch wie weit wagen sie sich da mit
einer aussage aus dem fenster wir haben
ja ein paar mechanismen die wir jetzt
gut beschreiben können die booster
kampagne läuft gut an wir haben uns
letztes mal festgelegt auf 30 millionen
booster impfungen bis ende des jahres
die hälfte davon haben wir schon ich
glaube das klappt in nordrhein westfalen
wird soviel gepusht wie nie zuvor
geimpft worden ist 1,4 millionen
angesetzte woche geschafft wir hatten
mal 1,1 auf dem höhepunkt der
impfkampagne mit den großen impfzentren
jetzt haben wir viele viele kleine auch
mobile einheiten das scheint effizienter
zu sein bin ich noch am herzen das thema
medikamente es kommen immer mehr
medikamente in die erprobung ich hoffe
auch bald in die zulassung da sollten
wir eine abgestimmte medikamenten
strategie zwischen bund und ländern
haben um menschen die früh erkrankt sind
sofort diese medikamente geben zu können
damit sie erst gar nicht ins krankenhaus
auf die intensivstation müssen ist eine
weitere säule neben der impfung die uns
aus dieser schlimmen situation raus
bringen kann als die letzte mal bei bild
live waren vor zwei wochen da haben sie
harte bußgelder auch angekündigt da ging
es um die kontrollen vor allen dingen in
bus und bahn und wir uns alle ein
bisschen gefragt wie will man das
kontrollieren ich selbst habe das hier
in berlin erlebt es wird also
kontrolliert haben sie beim thema
bußgelder schon zugelangt
beziehungsweise zu lang müssen in
nordrhein westfalen ja es wird
kontrolliert und es wird auch
kontrolliert werden ob die 2g regelungen
im freizeitbereich eingehalten werden im
handelsbereich eingehalten werden wir
werden die kommunen auch unterstützen
mit 50 millionen euro diese kontrollen
zu machen sind ja die kommunalen
ordnungsbehörden wir lassen sie als land
nicht alleine mit dieser aufgabe
wichtiger als all die kontrollen die
wichtig ist und sind und die wir machen
ist aber dass die menschen selber
vernünftig sind das machen fügt sich
dran halten und den anderen reiter
gelangen wird ist wird zugelangt es wird
kontrolliert werden bußgelder verhängt
das ist auch wichtig und trotzdem ist
mir noch einmal wichtig zu sagen der
appell an alle menschen das geschriebene
ist das eine haltet euch dran aber seid
auch darüber hinaus vorsichtig und
zurückhaltend wenn sie gesehen als sie
ministerpräsident gewonnen sind in
begleitung auch ihres babys das waren
sehr sehr schöne bilder die wir gesehen
haben ich weiß ihr kind es noch sehr
klein aber würden sie ihr kind impfen
lassen ja unser kind ist acht monate alt
dafür gibt es jetzt diesen impfstoff
noch nicht wir haben aber die frage
impfung generell natürlich auch zu hause
diskutiert mit blick auf andere
impfungen die auch bei kleinen kindern
bei babys schon ein stehen und wir haben
uns immer dafür entschieden aber das ist
unsere persönliche entscheidung bei
kindern finde ich muss man sehr
vorsichtig sein menschen zu sagen was
sie zu tun oder zu lassen haben da muss
man auch beraten was gibt es für
krankheitsbilder muss man ein kinderarzt
besprechen ist anders als bei
erwachsenen bei uns zu hause und danach
haben sie gefragt wir werden unser kind
impfen lassen wann immer das angezeigt
ist was muss noch passieren aktuell in
dieser corona krise um kinder besser zu
schützen
ja kinder schützen ist wichtig masken
pflicht in den schulen in nordrhein
westfälischen schulen wird so viel
getestet wie sonst nirgendwo dreimal die
woche werden die großen getestet zwei
mal die kleinen im pool test in den
kitas kriegen die eltern die tests mit
nach hause das ist alles wichtig vor
allem aber dafür dass kita betriebs
schulbetrieb stattfinden kann maximaler
schutz wie ich jetzt auch immer höhere
macht die schulen wieder zu ist nicht
meine politik wenn wir das irgendwie
vermeiden können will ich es vermeiden
weil die kinder die jungen leute haben
in der pandemie schon genug gelitten
dennoch macht das hier muss man sagen
auch so ein bisschen
die hintertür auch in einigen
bundesländern nehmen beispielsweise die
ferien verkürzt das findet natürlich
auch teilweise wechsel unterrichts
müssen teilweise ganze klassen in
quarantäne gehen also dennoch ist es für
kinder und auch für die eltern de facto
so dass das thema schule kein sicheres
das thema kinderbetreuung kita kein
sicheres thema in dieser krise ist wie
kann man das sicher machen im nordrhein
westfälischen schulen sind nicht mal ein
prozent der kinder positiv
getestet das heißt die schule denkt die
kita ist nicht per se eine infektion
streiber natürlich neben kinder nehmen
junge leute und infektionsgeschehen teil
wie andere auch sie sind eben vielfach
nicht geben falls die impfstoffe ja noch
gar nicht gegeben hat oder erst sehr
spät gekommen sind für die größeren
kinder deswegen ist die
durchimpfungsquote da besonders niedrig
und trotzdem finde ich haben wir als
stadt haben wir als gesellschaft eine
verpflichtung kinder junge leute zu
schützen dass die bildung dass sie auch
betreuung bekommen denn vieles was man
da versäumt kann man so einfach nicht
wieder nachholen wie lange angela merkel
deutschland regiert hat da es sich bei
uns zu hause immer an den kindern die
größte geboren als angela merkel das amt
übernommen hat die ist also jetzt 16
mensch so lange war diese ehre angela
merkel ihre tochter ist ganz klein wird
die jetzt eine ganz lange ära olaf
scholz kennenlernen und das wird ihr
kanzler
40 zeigen es gab kurze und lange kanzler
schafften in der geschichte der republik
ich habe gestern mit olaf scholz einen
kurzen moment mal diskutieren können
sprechen können wir sehen uns ja heute
wieder er war auch bei den letzten
ministerpräsidenten konferenzen ja schon
dabei das macht ja auch sinn im übergang
und ich habe ein großes interesse daran
dass wir gerade in dieser pandemie
zwischen bund und ländern gemeinsam
arbeiten dann schützen wir die menschen
am besten gerade dabei den mp cars was
oft so dass viele menschen sich gefragt
haben jetzt macht doch jeder wieder
wasser will eigentlich macht jedes
bundesland kocht noch mal sein eigenes
süppchen was glauben sie was muss die
politik tun weil jemand so eine mpk auch
nach außen transportiert werden damit
die menschen vertrauen gewinnen ein
konsistentes handeln ist wichtig und auf
der anderen seite müssen wir natürlich
schon konstatieren in bayern in sachsen
brandenburg thüringen haben wir völlig
andere situation als beispielsweise in
schleswig holsteins burg rensburg
rendsburg entschuldigung entschuldigung
nach schleswig holstein
innsbruck eckernförde so rum hat ganz
andere zahlen als meisten beispielsweise
deswegen ist mein anliegen einen
grundschutz zu verabreden denn alle
mitmachen und wer besondere
herausforderungen hat der muss natürlich
mehr machen dürfen und wo es gut ist
noch gut ist hoffentlich auch so bleibt
der muss eben nicht so viele
einschränkungen seinen bürgerinnen und
bürgern zumuten und das ist glaube ich
der richtige weg dass man im kern vieles
gleich macht aber daneben auch
möglichkeiten lässt reagieren auf die
lage vor ort er gibt den ton an in der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz beim corona
gipfel ich glaube es ist klug wenn da
gar keiner versucht in den klassenclown
zu machen sondern wenn man sehr eng
beieinander bleibt mein ton ist er
moderierend konziliant wir haben alle
was davon wenn wir schon zusammen
bleiben und das verträgt sie am besten
mit jemanden der diese mpk führt der das
auch im stil ausdrückt und alle leute
schön mitnimmt hat man sich da schon
vorher was überlegt wie man jetzt olaf
scholz zum ersten mal teilnehmen als
kanzler dort begrüßt nach ich glaube sie
einfach gratulieren aber es gibt keine
blumen kein wein kein geschenk kopf wer
gestern einiges gesehen lassen sich
überraschen letzte frage zielt auf die
cdu sie haben noch kein richtiges
gegengewicht gefunden zu olaf scholz
derzeit der sieht sich ja sowieso in der
kontinuität von angela merkel da wird's
schwierig dann eigene akzente vielleicht
in der opposition zu setzen glauben sie
dass die cdu jetzt schon im ersten
schwung sich auf einen neuen chef
festlegt also schon in der ersten
wahlrunde zum einen haben wir ja einen
chef im bundestag ralph brinkhaus der
auch in der lage ist im
parlamentarischen betrieb ein
gegengewicht zu setzen wenn es nötig ist
und wenn es nötig sein wird in den
nächsten wochen und ich bin ziemlich
sicher dann wird die cdu auch walter
neuen vorsitzenden aber schon in der
ersten runde gehen sie davon aus aus
entscheiden ja unsere mitglieder sagt
ich bin mitglied habe auch schon gewählt
sie haben sich festgelegt ich habe
gewählt wen haben sie denn gewählt das
werde ich nicht verraten warum haben wir
auch ein wahlgeheimnis bei solchen app
store hier man muss es nicht sagen aber
man kann sagen stimmt durch aber nicht
dank für ihren besuch hier im studio